in this video we explore how to turn
classroom rules into a classroom pledge
but your students want to follow the
idea is to get your students to help
write the rules in the form of a
classroom pledge this gives them
ownership of the classroom rules and
encourages them to help each other
behave divide your whiteboard into two
and ask your students to brainstorm
ideas about good classroom behavior and
how they should treat each other write
their ideas down on one side of the
board and repeat this process for things
they shouldn't do if you have young
students who can't read try having them
draw pictures as part of the
brainstorming process if any important
social skills are missing give your
students a hint or help them find it and
have them help combine similar ideas on
both sides be sure to thank them and
give them praise for their ideas your
goal is to reinforce positive behavior
with these two lists write your
classroom pledge for example in room 314
we are always kind listen to our teacher
ask a lot of questions and help each
other we don't say or do things that
hurt or take without asking we are here
to learn and do our best speak out your
pledge together once a day and your
students will want to help each other
follow their very own classroom rules if
you have your own ideas on how to
improve the classroom please let us know
in the comments and please post your own
versions of the classroom pledge we're
releasing updates regularly so don't
forget to subscribe to our channel thank
you for watching
you